si changer ainsi nous bienvenue dans la
classe de première année de madame annie
ici c'est fini les méthodes
d'enseignement traditionnel non
seulement l'aménagement de sa classe et
moins conventionnel mais surtout ses
élèves apprennent différemment pour moi
en tout cas c'est terminé août et
j'étais le maître du savoir lotus elle
qui parle tout l'avant midi puis qui va
dire ce qu'il veut mais n'est ce qu'on
essaie de faire le plus possible c'est d
espèce de mini leçons puis après son
s'envoler mettre en action
elle était entrée libre c'est ce qu'on
appelle la méthode collaborative ce qui
veut dire qu'il ya davantage de
collaboration entre les jeunes et les
enseignants
cette méthode tous les professeurs de
l'école accueille la clique depuis cette
année afin de favoriser une meilleure
réussite scolaire on n'est pas dans une
mentalité de découverte non plus
complètement au studio vega je te mets
chauds devant toi puis love aussi avec
ce qu'ils tentent le nom
je vois deux guides et on voit cette
collaboration s'opère aussi entre les
enseignants de tous les niveaux à
l'école l'accueil ils se rencontrent une
vingtaine de fois par année pour
partager les approches qui ont
fonctionné ou pas dans leur classe t'es
vraiment un moment où est-ce qu'on fait
un stop pour évaluer où est-ce qu'on en
est rendu avec nos élèves
le but de sow c'est qu'ils aient pas de
trous de la 1re à la 6e année et que
chacun sache qu est ce qui est attendu
dans le niveau suivant
ce ne sont pas que les profs de 6e année
qui sont imputables des résultats des
élèves
quand ils partent pour le secondaire que
ce que ce n'est deux ans ferme et
enseignants cesse donc de travailler en
silo avant c'était six courses 200 m où
à la fin de l'année le prof disait de la
course est finie
moi je m'en lave les mains maintenant on
fait plus une course à relais
d'ailleurs les élèves apprennent la même
matière au même moment de la première à
la sixième année au moment du tournage
toute l'école travailler sur les schémas
de récits l'avancé passe avant tout
chacun une fois que sa porte était close
faisait dans le fond ce qu'elle avait le
goût de faire la trame de foyers tpo
temps écouter la leçon si tu le fais
dans ton texte
c'est magnifique et cette méthode
collaboratif fonctionne du moins au
niveau de l'engagement des élèves de
tous les deux dit regretter c'était en
première année puis je te dis le vrai
c'est fini c'est qu'on arrive qu'ils
sont comme au sol au château d'igé une
pointe seul woods avait comme hier c'est
au niveau des résultats il faudra être
un peu plus patient même si les
enseignants constatent déjà certaines
améliorations c'est un projet vraiment
long terme
on investit pour nos enfants futurs
ça va nous prendre un bon dix ans avant
que tout soit bien implanté c'est le
temps que ça a pris à l'ontario lors de
sa réforme de l'éducation au début des
années 2000 maintenant la méthode
collaborative y est bien en place
le taux de diplomation des jeunes
ontariens et de 85 pour ça une dizaine
de points au dessus de celui du québec
pour que cette méthode collaborative
soit efficace ça prend de l'argent et
des financements stas faut permettre
c'est du temps de qualité à nos gens
pour qu'ils puissent vraiment s'asseoir
ensemble des enseignants qui sont
libérés donc c'est ça nous prend des
suppléants qui vont en classe
l'école accueille arrive notamment avec
l'aide de la fondation chagnon
mais aussi avec une gestion créative des
finances tels que ce serait dernière si
chaque école chaque commission scolaire
à ces défis c'est clair pour les
enseignants et la direction que c'est un
modèle à imiter mais limité selon à sa
réalité ses besoins et sa personnalité
oui ici marie pierre mercier radio
canada ascot en bourse